[Music]
Hey, I'm Will and with Noble Locksmith
and you're watching my YouTube channel,
Car Key Wizard. I'm an automotive
locksmith and while I definitely don't
know it all, I have learned some tricks
along the way that I hope will help you
while you're out in the field. One thing
you can do to help me out though would
be to subscribe to my channel. And if
you like my videos, leave a comment or
ask a question and I'll get back to you
as soon as I can. I make a lot of
videos, so if there's something you'd
like to learn more about or a video
you'd like to see on a car we're working
on, just let me know in the comments and
I'll put it up as soon as I can. Thanks,
and I hope you enjoy watching my videos.
[Music]
>> All right, good morning. Um, I've seen
all the comments. What does Ron look
like? Why do we only see the back of his
head? All right, that's not what
happened, but here I am. Hi. Um, we are
doing a
Hyundai Elantre. We're adding a prox
key.
I did the automatic select or yeah,
automatic selection. Read the car. Here
is the new key. It is the F2000
from Noble Key Supply. We're going to go
smart key.
This is a 2017, so I can't use the
dongle to get the PIN and the key code.
So, we're going to have to read it from
the car.
Read a Mobilizer password.
Reading this pin can take quite a while.
Uh, knowing which one of these to select
cuts it down. This is an 8A. I read the
key.
Yes. Turn the hazard lights on.
Turn the ignition off. Open and close
the door.
So, this does this, like I said, this
can take a pretty good while. So, I'm
going to pause this here. go duplicate
his key and come back hopefully with the
password.
We are back. There's my password. That
took a good five minutes. 195515.
So, we're going to go back
to keyless system
remote control learning. It's going to
give me the message that I need to put
both keys back in when we get in there.
Smart key learning.
There it is. We'll erase all existing
keys. It's just saying you got to
program the original key back if you're
going to lose it.
All that is done.
5515.
[Music]
All right. Hit okay. Push the button
with the key
this down here so we can see the lights
and cover up the other key.
All right.
Okay, push the button. Launch your
security lights. I don't know why it
said that. Never does that. Programming
succeeded. Would you like to program the
next one? Yes, I would. Same process.
Hit okay.
Hold the button down. That's going to
say programming succeeded. Number of
keys, two. Please exit the system. Uh
the limit on Hyundai Kia is two keys,
strangely. So that's all you can do. So,
that's that. And we are done here. We're
going to test these remotes. This
battery is dead. I'll change that for
him.
Mine
garbage truck. Start it up.
Good to go.
We're just going to change the battery
in his key so his remote works again and
get out of here.